[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
cette soirée est une première dans
l'histoire politique de ce pays et c'est
une première pour la télévision la
musique ça me replonge dans cette espèce
de quand même tensions gigantesques
vasques évidemment ça va présenter un
événement ultra important dans la vie
des cp et donc accessoirement dans la
mienne aussi les débats présidentiels à
télévision se résume dans l'histoire
politique de la vème république au grand
débat de l'entre-deux tours il n'y a pas
du tout cette culture qui est plutôt une
culture américaine des débats pour les
primaires je crois que c'est vraiment
l'intuition des deux présidents de
l'époque en fait d'avoir saisi et
compris peut-être avant les autres
chaînes que cet événement allait devenir
un événement médiatico politique et
toute sa bande alors sauté les premiers
en fait laurent fabius bonsoir soit
ségolène royal bonsoir dominique strauss
kahn bonsoir soir arrive ce premier soir
du débat là quand même toute la journée
on avait senti la tension monte et je
crois qu'il y avait un papier dans mon
jeu je crois qu'il y avait un pas puis
dans le parisien il y avait évidemment
jamais encore vraiment de papier
consacré à nous comme ça et en fait
c'est assez tardivement je crois que
j'ai pris conscience que j'ai à oui
quand même
alors ça ne vous a pas échappé le 16 ou
le 23 novembre prochain l'un d'entre
vous sera le candidat du parti
socialiste à la présidence de la
république
l'enjeu est donc de taille pour vous ce
soir les français vous regarde on avait
jean pierre elkabbach et richard michel
tous les deux dans l'oreillette mais on
avait beaucoup plus jean pierre
elkabbach a pas pu s'en empêcher enfin
je pense quand il avait alors ils
avaient envie d'être à votre place donc
il y serait bienvenue cuisiner ces trois
éléphants socialistes
je vous ai parlé des délocalisations
alors ce qu'admet vous m j'en parlerai
volontiers il vous reste 30 secondes
pour nous parler d une grande synthe
comme ségolène royal sinon on pourrait
pas en parler c'est normal là dessus je
pense qu'il faut qu'on revienne à ce qui
était dit au début et qui juste je me
souviens juste qu'à un moment il m'a dit
arrêté de sourire
alors je serai pas faire le voyage vous
sauriez trop vous avez un joli sourire
mais n'en abusez pas ça m'a évidemment
projets dans un désarroi terry parce que
je me disais bon que cela veut dire à
s'élargir d'une cruche à l'antenne en
revanche je pense que c'était aussi une
manière de contrôler mon émotion sûr que
sourire ça peut être aussi une façon de
sauver les provenances
[Musique]
c'est un nom de téléspectateurs auxquels
bien sûr à l'époque sur lcp on n'est pas
du tout habitués mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant en fait c'est que
depuis c'est vraiment devenu un genre
télévisuel en soi bien c'est tous
habitués à voir le débat des primaires à
gauche à droite mais il faut bien
mesurer qu'à l'époque c'est pas un
spectacle politique qu'en fait c'est un
spectacle auquel les français ne sont
pas du tout habitués
[Musique]